des images qui donnent froid dans le dos
celle d'une centrale nucléaire touchée
par des bombardements russes situé à
nerfs douar dans le centre du pays il
s'agit de la plus grande d'europe les
tirs ont provoqué un incendie qui a
finalement été maîtrisé un danger
nucléaire rapidement été écartée la
sécurité du site et maintenant garantie
oui au causse à fortune est tt rosenau
release of radiation hentati
integrity of d'aurillac
au compromis le président zelensky
accuse moscou d'avoir recours à la
terreur nucléaire dans votre beau span
6-0
au neuvième jour de l'offensive russe la
liste des villes bombardées s'allonge à
tchernihiv dans nord de l'ukraine des
tirs ont tué 45 personnes hier les
attaques qui visaient des zones
résidentielles se poursuivent
aujourd'hui
acquiert scène la plus grande
municipalité prises par les russes les
gens se massent devant les supermarchés
pour acheter de la nourriture mais un
peu partout au pays les biens de
première nécessité se font de plus en
plus rares les tablettes se fait
graduellement à odessa ville portuaire
plus à l'ouest les civils près par des
sacs de sable dans l'espoir de repousser
l'arrivée des troupes selon l'armée
ukrainienne des navires us et dirige il
s'agit d'une cible stratégique
aux abords de kiev l'artillerie russe a
réduit en cendres cette maison son
propriétaire un puissant la regarde
partir en fumée
nous n'avons entendu qu'un seul coup de
fil plus la moitié de la maison a été
détruite expliqué fbn c'est une bonne
chose que nos enfants soient sortis
juste avant
s'il avait été dans l'autre pièce ça
aurait été la fin pour rue raconte il la
gorge nouée du côté russe la liberté de
presse continuent d'être mises à mal le
kremlin sert sérieusement la vis aux
citoyens et journalistes toute personne
qui diffuse des informations jugées
mensongères sur l'armée s'expose
désormais acquise en prison
presque aussitôt de grands médias
internationaux comme la bbc radio canada
ont annoncé la suspension de leur
activité journalistique dans le pays ira
bon d'arrêter sous nos yeux monter dans
des autobus ici et me lemieux radio
canada montréal